de Blois à l'origine comme tous les
châteaux c'était aussi des jardins
extraordinaires des Louis XII on a des
traces de jardin ici à Blois et bien sûr
ça s'est développé à la Renaissance nous
sommes avec la responsable des parcs et
jardins de la ville de Blois Nathalie
Bernard c'est vous qui aujourd'hui est
en charge de l'entretien de ce qui reste
de ces jardins expliquez-nous qu'est-ce
que l'on sait des jardins aujourd'hui
disparus
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
reconstitution de jardin mais à l'époque
les jardins du château allaient depuis
la terrasse Gaston d'Orléans en passant
par une passerelle au-dessus des forêts
au dessus des des fossés du château et
prenez l'ensemble du site sur lequel on
est jusqu'à la forêt de Blois en passant
par les allées François 1er puisqu'en
fait les rois utilisaient ces espaces
pour aller chasser en forêt cet héritage
aujourd'hui pour la ville de Blois
qu'est-ce que c'est
alors cet héritage c'est aujourd'hui les
jardins des simples et des fleurs
royales dans lequel nous sommes
le du roi c'est la terrasse des lys qui
jardin qui ont été
proposés aux Rafa qui ont fait l'objet
d'un concours dans les années 90 et
qu'on était concours qui a été remporté
par Gilles Clément paysagiste de renom
qui est connu pour la théorie des
jardins en mouvement c'est le bicafé
aussi les jardins du quai Branly duréol
la proposer à la ville de Blois plutôt
que de faire une reconstitution de
jardin historique de faire une
réinterprétation de l'histoire avec des
différents jardins conçus en lien avec
l'histoire du château et les différentes
époques de construction du château je
vous propose à travers un reportage
d'essayer de reconstituer on va on va
voir ce qui était ces jardins disparus
je vous invite à regarder avec nous
[Musique]
alors là on est sur le belvédère des
jardins donc c'est un endroit qui se
trouve au bout de l'aile François 1er et
qui nous permet d'avoir une vue
imprenable sur les anciens jardins
royaux c'est grâce à un parchemin du
16ème siècle que l'on connaît
l'existence du jardin disparu du château
de Blois encore un peu d'inspiration
médiévale déjà dans le style italien de
la Renaissance ces jardins d'une
superficie de 6 hectares était un
élément indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de la cour des rois Louis
XII et François 1er on voit que ces
jardins était situé face au château et
qu'ils étaient accessibles via une
galerie qui enjambait l'ancien fossé du
moyen-âge et donc on arrivait dans ses
jardins qui étaient divisés en trois
grandes terrasses avec donc des
différences de niveau d'une terrasse à
l'autre et qui s'étendait donc à l'ouest
et sur une très grande surface on le
voit sur le dessin les jardins sont plus
grands que la surface du château
aujourd'hui ce premier jardin
Renaissance en France visite en virtuel
la ville de Blois s'était tendue
maintenant autour de son château
on est en 1570 ici sur la tablette et là
on est en 2023 et donc on voit tout ce
qui a changé et donc même si encore un
peu de verdure on voit bien la partie
haute du jardin mais on voit aussi donc
l'avenue qui est maintenant coupe les
jardins en deux pour aller à la gare
tonnelle vigne rosier noisetier non pas
survécu par contre quelques bâtiments et
accessoires en dur témoignent de la
beauté de ce jardin d'ornement alors ici
il y avait grande fontaine en marbre de
Cara recouverte en fait d'un édifice de
charpenterie avec une coupole à lanterne
donc une belle fontaine effectivement
qui permettait de se rafraîchir pour
répondre à l'engouement touristique sur
le thème des jardins en 2019 le château
royal de Blois a vegetalisé sa terrasse
sud le virtuel va permettre de se
projeter dans les jardins du 16e siècle
tel qu'ils ont été et puis la
reconstitution va permettre aussi de
réfléchir parce qu'ils ont été pensés
dans leur aménagement pour évoquer via
les perspectives qu'ils offrent ce qui
était des jardins la Renaissance qui
était des jardins ouverts sur des
perspectives et puis en terrasse donc
vous voyez il y a différents niveaux en
fait ici les plantations ont été
aménagées dans des bacs ce qui permet
d'évoquer ces terrassements en
reconstitution ou en virtuel le château
royal de Blois cultive son jardin
disparu
maintenant des jardins municipaux est-ce
que à l'avenir ça peut aussi être un
atout un développement pour vous et les
parcs et jardins
touristique puisque c'est vrai que il y
a un vrai tourisme de jardin qui se
développe en France on a plusieurs
petits jardins qui s'imbriquent le
jardin des simples zodiacaux cette
partie centrale avec une alternance de
détaillée de vivaces très souple qui
donne vraiment
l'esprit de Claude et jardin des jardins
de du Moyen-Âge la terrasse des lys en
lien avec la façade François 1er le
bastion du roi et dans sur la terrasse
d'Elise vous voyez qu'il y a un escalier
qui monte vers une grande esplanade qui
est qui était l'esplanade d'Elis qui
faisait partie du projet initial et qui
a pas été aménagée en même temps que les
autres jardins donc pourquoi pas un jour
voilà le réaménagement de cette place
dans la continuité de ces jardins de ces
jardins une visite de jardin remarquable
voilà qui peut accompagner de la visite
du château royal de Blois